[Music]
[Applause]
here at rotten tomatoes we understand
the hard work and dedication that goes
into making a movie
that's why it takes twice as much to
remake a movie because it's just math
right
today we're looking at best movie
remakes and we're talking about the
worlds stories and characters that we
couldn't get enough of once so we had to
go back for seconds
okay do you want to play with okay
shout out to my new friend
for this list we included titles with at
least 10 reviews and that were ranked
highest by tomato meter so refill your
popcorn and rearrange your cushions
because we are about to revisit some old
favorites and count down the best movie
remakes of all time
[Music]
number 10 the thing
in remote antarctica a group of american
research scientists are disturbed at
their base camp by a helicopter shooting
at a sled dog when they take in the dog
it brutally attacks both human beings
and canines in the camp and they
discover that the beast can assume the
shape of its victims a resourceful
helicopter pilot and the camp doctor
lead the camp crew in a desperate gory
battle against the vicious creature
before it picks them all off one by one
starring kurt russell wilford brimley
keith david and directed by john
carpenter critics say grimmer and more
terrifying than the 1950s take john
carpenter's the thing is a tense sci-fi
thriller right with compelling tension
and some remarkable makeup effects
let's do it
get me out of here
get me loose
get me the hell come on get me out of
here come on get me out of here cut me
loose damn it
i know you gentlemen have been through a
lot
and when you find the time
i'd rather not spend the rest of this
winter tied to this
couch
number nine ocean's eleven
dapper danny ocean is a man of action
less than 24 hours into his parole from
a new jersey penitentiary the rye
charismatic theme is already rolling out
his next plan following three rules of
course don't hurt anybody don't steal
from anyone who doesn't deserve it and
play the game like you've got nothing to
lose danny orchestrates the most
sophisticated elaborate casino heist in
history starring george clooney matt
damon brad pitt and directed by steven
soderbergh critics say as fast-paced
witty and entertaining as it is
star-studded and coolly stylish ocean's
11 offers a well-seasoned serving of
popcorn entertainment
do not blow the door linus can you read
me
maybe the pinch blew out is there minus
can you read me do not blow the door
two
one
something
check the batteries
no
you lose focus in this game for one
second i know somebody gets hurt i don't
hear yen complaining
number eight let me in
bullied at school neglected at home and
incredibly lonely twelve-year-old owen
spends his days plotting revenge on his
tormentors and spends his nights spying
on other residents of the apartment
complex his sole friend is abby a
strange girl who comes out only at night
time both outcasts the two form a strong
bond when abby's caretaker disappears
amid a series of gruesome murders owen
begins to suspect that she is hiding a
terrible secret starring cody smith
mcphee chloe grace moretz richard
jenkins and directed by matt reeves
critics say similar to the original in
all the right ways but with enough
changes to stand on its own let me in is
the rare hollywood remake that doesn't
add insult to inspiration
[Music]
[Music]
no no no stop stop coming
what was that
i don't know
i just know this is what happens if you
don't invite me
number seven 310 to yuma outlaw ben wade
terrorizes 1800s arizona especially the
southern railroad until he is finally
captured wade must be brought to trial
so dan evans the owner of a
drought-stricken ranch volunteers to
escort him to the train along the trail
a grudging respect forms between the men
but danger looms at every turn and the
criminal's men are in pursuit starring
russell crowe christian bale logan
lerman and directed by james mangold
critics say this remake of a classic
western improves on the original thanks
to fiery performances from russell crowe
and christian bale as well as sharp
direction from james mangold
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
number six the departed
south boston cop billy costigan goes
undercover to infiltrate the
organization of gang land chief frank
costello as billy gains the mobster's
trust a career criminal named colin
sullivan infiltrates the police
department and reports on its activities
to his syndicate bosses when both
organizations learn that they have a
mole in their midst billy and colin must
figure out each other's identities to
save their own lives starring leonardo
dicaprio matt damon jack nicholson and
directed by martin scorsese critics say
featuring outstanding work from an
excellent cast the departed is a
thoroughly engrossing gangster drama
with the gritty authenticity and soupy
morality come to expect from martin
scorsese i got this rat this
annoying
eating
all right
and it brings up questions
you know see bill like you're the new
guy
girlfriend
why don't you stay in the bar that night
i got your numbers
social security numbers
everybody's numbers is is this something
that you just want to go ahead and ask
me because i'll give you the [ __ ]
answer all right
frank look at me look at me
i'm not the [ __ ] rat okay
i'm not the [ __ ] rat
start whether you agree there is a rat
you said there is one all right i base
most of what i do on the idea that
you're pretty good at what you do
number five west side story
love at first sight strikes when young
tony spots maria at a high school dance
in 1957 new york city their burgeoning
romance helps to fuel the fire between
the warring jets and sharks two rival
gangs vying for control of the streets
starring ansel elgort rachel zegler
ariana dubose rita moreno and directed
by steven spielberg critics say steven
spielberg's west side story presents a
new look at the classic musical that
lives up to its beloved forebear and in
some respects might even surpass it
you're back where you came from
you think i want to stay here
in a city full of ugly little animals
like you
no gracia
americana
you tell that murderer
maria ain't coming
do you know
he found out about them tony and maria
he shot her
maria is dead
you tell him that
number four invasion of the body
snatchers
this remake of the classic horror film
is set in san francisco matthew bonnell
assumes that when a friend complains of
her husband's strange mood it's a
marital issue however he begins to worry
as more people report similar
observations his concern is confirmed
when writer jack belichick and his wife
discover mutated corpse besieged by an
invisible enemy matthew must work
quickly before the city is consumed
starring donald sutherland brooke adams
leonard nimoy and directed by philip
kaufman critics say employing gritty
camera work and evocative sound effects
invasion of the body snatchers is a
powerful remake that expands upon themes
and ideas only lightly explored in the
original
[Music]
go on keep on running don't stop
go on
[Music]
this way follow me
[Music]
number three the fly
when scientist seth brundle completes
his teleportation device he decides to
test its abilities on himself
unbeknownst to him a housefly slips into
the process leading to a merger of man
and insect initially brundle appears to
have undergone a successful
teleportation but the fly cells begin to
take over his body as he becomes
increasingly fly-like brundle's
girlfriend is horrified as the person
she once loved deteriorates into a
monster starring jeff goldblum gina
davis john getz and directed by david
cronenberg critics say david cronenberg
combines his trademark affinity for gore
and horror which strongly developed
characters making the fly a surprisingly
affecting tragedy
[Music]
so
[Music]
number two true grit
after an outlaw named tom chaney murders
her father feisty 14 year old farm girl
maddie ross hires rooster cogburn a
boozy trigger happy law man to help her
find cheney and avenge her father the
bickering duo are not alone in their
quest for a texas ranger named lebe is
also tracking cheney for reasons of his
own together the unlikely trio ventures
into hostile territory to dispense some
old west's justice starring jeff bridges
matt damon haley seinfeld and directed
by joel and ethan cohen critics say
girded by strong performances from jeff
bridges matt damon and newcomer haley
steinfeld and lifted by some of the
cohen's most finely tuned unaffected
work true grit is a worthy companion to
the charles portis book
i will just
go far
there
there my bullet your bullet if you hit
what you aim at explain my shoulder man
shooting cornbread out here on the
prairie is getting us no closer to the
ned pepper gang one more
this will prove it
please fire
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
scarface
after getting a green card in exchange
for assassinating a cuban government
official tony montana stakes a claim on
the drug trade in miami viciously
murdering anyone who stands in his way
tony eventually becomes the biggest drug
lord in the state controlling nearly all
the cocaine that comes through miami but
increased pressure from the police wars
with colombian drug cartels and his own
drug-fueled paranoia serve to fuel the
flames of his eventual downfall starring
al pacino michelle pfeiffer stephen
bauer and directed by brian de palma
critics say director brian de palma and
star al pacino take it to the limit in
this stylized ultra violent and
eminently quotable gangster epic that
walks a thin line between moral drama
and celebratory excess
you're gonna have her i go away i'm
gonna disappear tony you'll never see me
again tony please i don't want to die i
never did nothing to nobody
no no no you never did nothing
but that's right you had somebody else
do it for me
[Music]
oh chris thank you
get up
no
every dog has his day
dawn of the dead
when her husband is attacked by a
zombified neighbor anna manages to
escape only to realize that her entire
milwaukee neighborhood has been overrun
by the walking dead after being
questioned by cautious policeman kenneth
anna joins him and a small group that
gravitates to the local shopping mall as
a bastion of safety once they convince
suspicious security guards that they are
not contaminated the group bands
together to fight the undead hordes
starring sarah paulie ving rhames jake
weber and directed by zack snyder
critics say a kinetic violent and
surprisingly worthy remake of george
romero's horror classic that pays homage
to the original while working on its own
terms
[Applause]
run
[Applause]
up
[Applause]
come on let's go
feedback
[Music]
and before we get to number one here is
another honorable mention
the mummy
the mummy is a rousing suspenseful and
horrifying epic about an expedition of
treasure-seeking explorers in the sahara
desert in 1925. stumbling upon an
ancient tomb the hunters unwittingly set
loose a 3 000 year old legacy of terror
which is embodied in the vengeful
reincarnation of an egyptian priest who
had been sentenced to an eternity as one
of the living dead starring brendan
fraser rachel weiss john hannah and
directed by steven sommers critics say
it's difficult to make a persuasive
argument for the mummy as any kind of
meaningful cinematic achievement but
it's undeniably fun to watch
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey get your ugly face off for her
look what i got
[Music]
[Applause]
and finally number one the wizard of oz
when a tornado rips through kansas
dorothy and her dog toto are whisked
away in their house to the magical land
of oz they follow the yellow brick road
toward the emerald city to meet the
wizard and in route they meet a
scarecrow that needs a brain a tin man
missing a heart and a cowardly lion who
wants courage the wizard asks the group
to bring him the broom of the wicked
witch of the west to earn his help
starring judy garland frank morgan bert
lahr and directed by victor fleming
critics say an absolute masterpiece
whose groundbreaking visuals and death
storytelling are still every bit as
resonant the wizard of oz is a must-see
film for young and old
total
i have a feeling we're not in kansas
anymore
[Music]
we must be over the rainbow
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of that
entertainment content that you love
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you